[Musik]
mit ins gericht
hallo herzlich willkommen so sally cells
wir sind gerade in burgers fieber und
deswegen gibt auch heute ein richtig
leckeres burger rezept also wenn ihr mal
in einer stadt sind weil wir leben hier
auszuwischen offen lang erwartete ich
zwar auch eine start up noch klein
wenn wir mal in einer größeren stadt wie
heidelberg zum beispiel oder in münchen
gibt es auch gehen wir wirklich immer
ganz gerne zu hans im glück
das ist ein richtig cooler burger laden
und dort ist immer einen burger aber ich
probiere immer ich sag immer
kontrolliert wo will man in anderen
bürger aus aber nicht es dann doch immer
den gleichen weil wir eben nicht so oft
dort sind doch letztlich immer gerne den
beeten walschburger
und ich möchte ihn heute jetzt machen
natürlich gehe ich das originalrezept
nicht aber ich mach nach bestem wissen
und gewissen und wehrt euch jetzt
einfach mal die zutaten vorstellen für
die sour cream brauche ich 200 gramm
saure sahne einen bund schnittlauch salz
und pfeffer für die champignons habe ich
hier 200 gramm braune champignons einen
esslöffel wo das paprikapulver in edel
will einen esslöffel butter und zum
belegen habe ich hier etwas zeigen sein
rucola eine rote zwiebel entsprach 4
pettys aus rindfleisch und vier bürger
beim und die bürger dann habe ich
bereits vorbereitet da gibt es einen
grund versetzt bei mir auf dem kanal und
die rindfleisch parties die werde ich
jetzt gleich wieder ins gefrierfach
stellst da brauche ich jetzt vier stück
was vier portionen werden
und die habe ich so gemacht dass ich mir
in dollar eingekauft habe linde hat
einen guten gehalt also von mindestens
25 prozent
so schneide ich dann gerne in kleine
stücke da passt auch am besten wenn das
fleischwerk halt ist das heißt ihr könnt
auch gerne kurz einfrieren bevor es da
durch den fleischwolf jagd und dann habt
ihr wirklich das perfekte fleisch das
könnt ihr dann entweder mit den händen
zu passiv formen oder ihr nehmt einfach
einen penny frau und kind so wirklich
ganz gleichmäßig große tennisprofi lässt
zum vorbereiten jetzt geht's direkt zum
birkenwald burger und staffel werde ich
jetzt erst einmal die backen herstellen
da gibt es hier
die bauer cream also die saure sahne und
wird jetzt einfach den schnittlauch in
feine röllchen schneiden
[Musik]
die kommen jetzt eben die sauerei andere
wird noch mit salz und pfeffer
[Musik]
dieser creme dafür auch ein bisschen
kräftiger gewürzt sein denn bei mir wird
es vielleicht nicht gewusst ich möchte
einfach den eigenen geschmack nicht
verändern und daher könnt ihr hier auch
ein bisschen mehr salz verwenden sie
schon mal bereit gestellt jetzt nehme
ich die champignons und schneit die in
feine scheiben
die butter in einer pfanne und david so
daß ich sogleich die chance darin
anbraten kann und während mutter warm
wird kann ich schon mal die zwiebel in
ringe schneiden
[Musik]
ihr könnt hier die busse mit den braun
werden lassen dann schmeckt ein bisschen
mutiger und kräftiger
jetzt werden einfach die champignons von
angebraten und im prinzip kann ich den
grill anschmeißen denn auch gleich
geschafft ist alles vorbereitet und wir
werden heute wieder auf der terrasse
grillen das heißt los geht's an dem
grill jetzt hier meiner petit und die
leg ich jetzt nacheinander drauf und die
können richtig gefroren sein
es gibt nichts schöneres als so einem
wetter draußen zu grill
jetzt lasse ich die partie hier liegen
und ihr wisst dann ob sie fertig sondern
bereits hin zum drehen wenn man sie dann
ganz einfach hoch bekommt also jetzt
einfach drei bis vier minuten so stehen
lassen
die berger band habe ich jetzt auch
schon vor allem auch aufgeschnitten und
die platte ich einfach nur noch kurz
[Musik]
ein
da
[Musik]
jetzt sind die bürger fertig und ich
kann sie servieren sie platz und starb
letzten bürger zusammen also dafür
nehmen sie ein butterbrot
da kommt es einen konsens drauf dann
nämlich jetzt einen feigen sind perfekt
gemacht auf der region aus altersheim
darauf dass fleisch kommt jetzt
schnittlauch woche drauf darauf ein
bisschen paprikapulver okay und ich
werde nicht die sally wenn ich nicht
auch ein bisschen zu dick aufgeben würde
noch die weiteren top hengst also
zwiebeln unternehme ich furchtbar gerne
rote zwiebeln schmecken einfach richtig
aromatischen sind auch sehr gesund
rucola ich glaube dann hab ich alles
deckel drauf und einzelstücke
lecker und dem papier
unglaublich lecker wirklich super lecker
also den burger müsst ihr auf jeden fall
mal ausprobieren
falls er die zutatenliste sucht gibt es
auf meinem blog stell ich mir dort
glaubten wir mit einem sieg setzen und
die richtig leckeren burger essen
ich trat gleich noch einen denn meine
nachbarin sitzt auf der terrasse und ich
glaube es hat auch ein bisschen hunger
bekommen bis zunächst mal
[Musik]
warum
genommen
[Musik]